as we mentioned a little earlier in the
show we're doing our 25th anniversary
what's interesting is that the basic
information the core of what we do in 25
years has not changed we still tell you
and have from the very first day we went
on the air to live on less than you make
you're not in Congress in the house of
the wise there are stores of choice food
and oil but a foolish man devours only
has if you spend everything you make
you're a fool I've been a fool some of
you have been a fool most of us have at
one time or another in our life we still
tell you to get out of debt that's
simple well Dave Ramsey makes me mad
I don't like Dave Ramsey Dave Ramsey
this Dave Ramsey that Twitter and
Facebook fools out there floating around
most of them not even born yet
when I started doing this show and
everybody's got an opinion you ever
notice how many broke people have
opinions about money it's like fat
people having opinions about marathons
just stupid just a dumb idea you know
and I used to be a lot nicer when I
first started the show I would try to
convince everyone and I was kind and it
really upset me when someone didn't like
me or was mad about something I said and
after doing this this long and 15
million books sold and five million
people through Financial Peace
University and the 14 million of you
listening here every week through one
version or another of this show I'm
pretty convinced now based on how many
people have become millionaires and how
many people have gotten out of debt and
how many people have increased their
generosity and how many people have
saved their marriage that was about to
fall apart over money I'm pretty
convinced now that on these money
subjects if you're upset by what I say
it's probably because you need to change
you're a whiner if you don't agree with
me on this stuff you're what's known as
wrong
well that's arrogant now not arrogant at
all it's confidence there's a difference
in confidence and arrogance I've been
doing this more than anyone else in the
entire world while you that are
listening to me have been alive
there's no one else on the planet that
has gotten as many people out of debt
that has caused as many people to be
millionaires no one else now there's a
lot of stuff I'm not good at and there's
a lot of stuff I don't know anything
about and yes I'm not perfect I get all
of that and this is not about me but
it's pretty aggravating after all this
time that some of you are still trying
to convince your friends and relatives
to do stupid stuff with money it's
aggravating because when you do convince
them to do stupid stuff with money
you're causing them to be broke you are
a curse in their lives
oh don't pay off your mortgage Dave
Ramsey doesn't know he's talking about
let me just a sweetheart you get your
mortgage paid off life doesn't get much
better you don't have a payment in the
world you've got what's known as money
the borrower is slave to the lender and
you can't sophisticate you know you Dave
Ramsey stuffs good for broke people it's
good for regular people but it's not
good for rich people or you stupid twit
what are your parents cousins of course
it's good for rich people how do you
think they got rich doing this stuff
what an idiotic statement and people to
say that dumbest things and the price
you know the social media is just
wonderful I love I love the fact I can
jump on Twitter with an idea and 800,000
people see it instantaneously I love
that it's kind of cool I mean it really
isn't it there's a lot of fun stuff
about Facebook you can do but I'll tell
you what the other thing it's done is
it's given voice it's given people who
shouldn't have an opinion a place to
have one I mean you know you're living
in your mother's basement writing a blog
on Finance really you should stay off
the computer son and get a job seriously
you ought to go make an income somewhere
well it is my job
listen you're 29 it's time to get out of
your mother's basement really well you
know the lot of us just clickbait
someone trying to get you know the use
of my name now to lift up there a
ridiculous process but here's the deal
25 years later still works get out of
debt live on less than you make live on
a written plan called a budget save
money for emergencies for kids college
and long term investing to change your
family tree be outrageously generous for
those of us that are evangelical
Christians that's a tie the tenth of our
income at least to our local church it
changes everything when you learn to
handle money personal finances
80-percent behavior it's only 20% of
head knowledge the guy in the mirror is
my problem if I can control that guy he
can be skinny and rich and here's what
happens no money is not the answer to
everything these are biblical financial
principles I don't know if I agree with
would do rims uses well how about the
Bible well just you know let's argue
with me look it up in the Bible doofus
it's in there I mean there's nothing
crazier than a crazy Christian some of
you people are Froot Loops I'm serious
it's ridiculous and and you argue while
sitting there broke that's what's weird
you know these broke people run around
with these passionate opinions and you
know it's a dr. Phil moment how's that
working for you
maybe it's time to change all of us have
to look up and say at some point I've
had enough that's it I've had it I'm not
living like this anymore I'm
on and that happened to me when I went
broke because I was stupid I mean I got
a pH D and D U and B I've done stupid
with zeros on the end I know exactly
what it looks like I know how it feels
to be so scared you can't breathe your
lights are cut off your water is being
cut off they're gonna foreclose on your
house and you got two little kids living
there my wife would have left but she
didn't have the money I mean we were
fighting like hillbillies man cuz we are
you know it was crazy it was out of
control I know how that feels some of
you are there right now and I'll never
pick on you for being there right now
I'll never pick on you based on your
income I'll never pick it but I will
pick on you for continuing to argue
about staying in stupid if you're stuck
on stupid don't call me want to argue
with me about that it won't be good for
you because I'm gonna bust you for your
own good cuz you got to get unstuck man
you can't keep doing the same thing over
and over again and expecting a different
result that's the definition of insanity
if the set of behaviors about handling
money your viewpoints your big-time
philosophies about money have brought
you to where you are and you don't like
where you are you probably need some new
ideas darling and maybe you need to get
off your high horse if you're broke and
quit telling everybody how smart you are
about money because the fruit in your
life says you're not it says you're
stupid I've been stupid I know how it
feels it cause you be broke so just
decide which way you want to live that's
what's interesting about this show for
25 years these things have never changed
the only thing that's changed is I'm a
whole lot blunt more blunt than I used
to be and I probably got less patients
I'm still fairly patient with somebody's
hurting but I got less patience with
somebody who wants to be broke and
stupid and argue about it I just it's
just dumb to me it doesn't make any
sense
so that's why I reach over on Twitter
occasionally and just knock the crap out
of somebody just because it's fine
just fine
oh but you're thin-skinned I'm not
thin-skinned somebody criticizes you
says something on Twitter that they
should then they have the guts to say to
your face you smack them that's not
thin-skinned that's just called smack it
on what suffocation of America this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]